thank
you Hunter's art dealer throws him under
the bus and the crackheads appearance
causes a fuss Hunter Bine surprised
everyone when he unexpectedly popped up
at a house Committee hearing to hold him
in contempt this morning that's a switch
usually it's only parts of Hunter that
pop
up he even brought his so-called sugar
brother with him meaning the lawyer who
gives him millions of dollars for no
apparent reason
Hunter dodged reporters questions but
was unable to dodge our very own Hillary
vaugh Mr Biden why did you put your dad
on speaker phone with your business
partners if he had no involvement in
your
business do you have a dad does he call
you you answer the phone yes but why did
you need to talk to him during business
meetings if he had nothing to do with
your business so Hunter ask her do you
have a dad does he call you but are
those the same question he poses to
hookers during the selection process yes
ex who's your daddy don't have one come
with me who's your daddy does he call
you meanwhile Hunter's art dealer
confessed that Hunter actually knew most
of the people who bought his pieces
contrary to what the White House kept
telling us remember how an Ethics plan
was supposed to keep the buyers a secret
to avoid conflicts of interest with the
White House turns out the plan was as
real as Joe imaginary
friend in fact house oversight chair
James comr says dem donors purchased a
vast majority of Hunter paintings
including one woman Elizabeth H naft Hol
who got a cushy appointment to a
commission after purchasing his art for
tens of thousands of dollars not bad for
a guy who only picked up a paintbrush a
couple of years ago because he thought
he could smoke
it now he wasn't the only political
Person of Interest Who bought Hunter
paintings we actually got our hands on
more of the documents that reveal more
buyers here's a piece that Liz Warren
[Applause]
bought here's a picture of kamla Harris
bought here's what the mayor of San
Francisco
bought here's something Hillary Clinton
snatched
up and this is her husband Bill
bought I think that was too old though
yeah probably you know Emily uh I love
how the people always defend this by
saying there's no direct evidence of
cash Changing Hands isn't that what
defines money laundering there is no
direct exchange nobody goes here's a
million dollars Hunter Biden give it to
your dad it's not that's not how it
works and in terms of that I think the
clearest it would ever get is what
exactly was laid out before us which is
the vast majority of those purchasers of
Hunter weak to totally poor art were
Democratic donors and that main one who
enjoyed a cushy commission spot right
after she dropped $850,000 on a piece of
and we're supposed to accept this as oh
he's natural I mean at what point do the
Democrats look themselves in the mirror
and say I can't believe everyone is
buying these lies out of our mouths and
at what point will they agree to some
type of accountability comr is spending
the majority of his paycheck
ascertaining just how horrible how
corrupt of a family the bidens are and
that's the tip of the iceberg for what
we're learning and by the way that V
Hillary Von exchange with Biden it's
really notable that he did not deny it
and not only did he not deny it but he
insinuated that the president or vice
president at the time called him so when
she said why did you put your dad on
speaker phone he says doesn't you know
doesn't your dad call you so is that
what happened Hunter did your dad call
you during those business meetings so
many questions need to have answers and
the Democrats laughing this off or
trying to explain it off it's not good
enough cat did you catch any of that
stuff this morning the uh the so-called
circus uh I saw some of it in the
elevator kind of same do you think we
should buy this we could totally expense
it why why we should buy one of his
paintings and have it here on the set
okay well I
know we wouldn't do that and I and I
know for a fact that so they said the
majority of them are democratic donors I
would say a 100% of people who bought
the paintings were looking for people to
at least think they had influence so if
you bought it and Hunter knew about it
that's obvious but if you bought it and
he doesn't know about it you hope that
people will think that you have those
connections CU you have the painting yes
I know for a fact that everyone's buying
it for influence and not buying it
because they like how it looks because
of one reason which is there are no
prints of it being sold as posters on
Amazon that's true true that's mon yes
van go yes Biden no no not at all Tyrus
is it it's kind of it's more like Joe's
fault than Hunter because Hunter just
assumed Joe was going to retire so no
one would know about all this and then
he decided to run I blame Joe I I blame
Hunter 1000 the only thing I don't I
don't get is he knows he can't keep a
secret mhm clearly if you are trying to
do dirt and you have it all on let's say
a lap top you don't take it to a place
that specializes in fixing laptops and
can see all the evidence and hiding it
there so that was the first clue that
he's not the slickest one when it comes
to hiding stuff he's also like that with
childbearing so he's just not good at
hiding stuff I think this whole thing
was a miscommunication I think he showed
up today thinking it was something else
I think because you know he's been on
the Run he's been laying low he heard a
rumor that there was a sex party in the
senate floor he brought his homeboys
they walked in they're like what where
the the naked people why are
we yo bro I think this is your hearing
what yeah so I think it was it was more
of that and then he thought he was going
to have that animal house moment where
he gets out and walks out and deems worm
stands up that's it you're finished pal
you're done you're through we're going
to take your Charter no they were just
like get out crackhead so I mean it's
just
he just does things I think at this
point uh Joe and Jill should start
thinking about maybe
[Laughter]
[Applause]
aborting is it called late term yeah
that's a super late term Ultra late term
and I think it is legal I think it is
legal uh the Dems will be Pro uh yeah
yeah yeah you know maybe he was
expecting a sexual congress not an
actual Congress Le uh is the
administration's goal is to just make
this you know they have to protect Joe
right is that possible so far they've
been able to protect him I mean over the
course of the first year or so of the
Trump Administration and Don Jr would
already testified three times in these
closed door
depositions and Hunter and James Biden
and Sarah Biden I mean they haven't had
one closed door deposition yet they're
just kind of running out the clock into
what is now the election year and for
these Democrats who are covering for the
bidens and they keep on saying that
there's no evidence of absolutely
anything if the shoe was on the other
foot if Donald Trump was sitting in the
White House and one of his kids decide
to take up finger painting too and they
sell one of these pieces for a massive
sum of money and then the buyer ends up
getting all sorts of access or benefit
from the administration man these
Democrats would be losing their minds
they'd be looking for you know a
thousand years imprisonment for the
entire family they' want hundreds of
millions of dollars to get paid and F
they will want investigations and
impeachments and hangings MH we all see
this for exactly what it is and even
though they are successfully running out
the clock and there is this thing in
November called an election right they
don't have to keep them there for four
more years yeah that's true well we'll
see won't we I just coined that phrase
we'll
see that's why I'm the host hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else